the only thing that can be short of
about the future is it will be
absolutely fantastic
[Music]
welcome to the into the impossible
podcast a production of UC San Diego's
arthur c-- clark center for human
imagination and it's a real treat to
have one of my heroes my heroines
however you want to say it in physics
and not only a physicist we have a lot
of physicists on the show but an
experimental physicist you may be one of
the first if not the first
honest-to-goodness experimentalist who
has come on this program so thank you
Alan oh it's a real treat to have you
here that's nice words yes yes
absolutely and it's wonderful to have
you here I want to give a brief
introduction for the few people out
there who may not know you you were born
next week in the time that I won't
mention but your birthday is March 12th
which is a which is only two days before
Einstein's birthday so there are and
unfortunately Stephen Hawking's date of
being deceased was March 14th I believe
and she is an Italian American particle
physicist she's been a professor at
Columbia University since 1986 she's the
founder and spokesperson in the Xenon
Dark Matter experiment which is a major
component of our conversation today
she's known for her work with noble gas
noble liquid detectors and our
contributions to particle astrophysics
in the particular search for dark matter
which was the subject of your visit or
your talk that you gave to the public as
part of the arthur c clarke Center for
human imagination we screened a film
that you're in so you're not only a
wonderfully accomplished physicist a
professor at the top Ivy League
university but you're also a movie star
and I think you know I mentioned to you
earlier my wife thought I was
interviewing Sophia Loren oh I saw the
film last night
but I do want to just mention a brief
background you were student in the
University of Naples you were at Harvard
and the 80s working as a postdoctoral
researcher for Carla Rubio's group who's
a well-known Nobel
Laureate and the subject of a book
called noble dreams and I'm not sure if
you make a cameo in that book you may
you may not I forgot well I'm I'm I'm
crying liquid argon tears so she's had
so many awards but though I focus on one
of them she's NSF Career Award
she received a medal of physiology
little public on italiana from the
Italian president Carlo behave she has
an asteroid named after her so that is a
type of dark matter which is named after
you an asteroid 26 86 86 Elena a prio no
way yeah discovered by telling image
amateur astronomer Silvano cazuli in
2006 do you know that I know it check
Wikipedia folks of course she received
the Lancelot and Berkeley New York
Community Trust Prize for meritorious
work in astronomy from the American
Astronomical Society and she is gracing
us this quarter at UC San Diego as one
of our Margaret burbage visiting
professors so welcome again and I want
to talk about right now I want to talk
about Margaret Burbidge because the
visiting professorship that you hold
currently in honor is named in honor of
my colleague Margret burbage who is a
hundred years young and she lives up in
the bay area of California but she as
one of the founding members of the
Center for Astrophysics in space
sciences where we found ourselves today
and among many of her distinctions
ranging from the not the Royal
astronomer there's some controversy
about that but she was the astronomer
who led the Greenwich Observatory she
was president I believe of the American
Astronomical Society many many things
she was one of the leaders and founders
of this Center that were in now but she
also among her many honors she trained
in some sense and befriended a young
astronomer by the name of veer Rubin and
of course be Rubin is well known as
being credited with finding some of the
most convincing evidence for the
existence of dark matter so I wanted to
just highlight that fact that UCSD has
this deep connection through Margaret
burbage and Jeff burbage
her husband the two of them were very
close with Vera Rubin and her husband
when she did a sabbatical here in the
60s that's when she learned a lot about
the type of spectroscopic studies that
she could later use to measure rotation
curves of these distant galaxies and
really provide some convincing evidence
for the existence of dark dark matter so
I want to ask you first what is it about
dark matter what why does it transfix
the imagination is it the name is it
this mysterious properties that it has
of seeming and non interactivity because
I know a lot of people who don't like to
interact or very introverted but dark
matter seems to be quite introverted in
a sense what fascinates people and maybe
ask you what what interests you the most
about dark matter I think simply is
because if you think that we we I mean
the stuff that we know makes such a
little amount in this universe is just
how can you not think about finding out
what the rest is so I don't know if the
name is correct this dark matter we know
we narrative from sweet Keira but yeah
what is it about it I think we have to
do it I mean there is no other way I
mean it's so important because when you
tell your children or your friends I
mean what are you doing is studying dark
matter and and the way I usually
presented is that we're trying to find
out what the 95 percent of the universe
is made of and they say what you mean
what did 95 percent of the universe is
made of because I mean for normal people
this is an intriguing question but for
us is much more intriguing because the
connection about dark matter and what it
is in particle physics and what we
learned all this life about the building
blocks of nature and the fundamental
laws of physics all that can change once
we find out what this dark matter is
soon it's the connection for me is the
connection with astrophysics astronomy
cosmology particle physics which
actually is the most appealing I mean I
cannot think of another topic today
which unifies all this is this
things right and I guess you know some
of the question that then naturally
comes up is is dark matter a new type of
material is it actually matter or could
it somehow be you know a placeholder for
some ignorance that we might have about
how gravity works can you say something
about whether or not this is still a
deep controversy within your field I no
I wouldn't say it's a deep controversy
but we have had mon modified gravity
theories and we are more recently heard
about this a new theory of gravity from
our friend Eric fair Linda so it's not a
controversy but there are people out
there who might and I don't know if
they're correct we don't know it's it's
plausible but any new theory would have
to explain all the phenomenon that we
see and observe and as far as I know to
date none of these theory that some of
these people have put forward are able
to explain fully the observations that
we have at all scales until then I'm
just keep looking the sort of a thorny
issue that I've thought about a lot
which is how do you know when to stop
doing an experiment when we teach our
undergraduates there's a known answer
that they're trying to get and they stop
when they get something that's
reasonably close to that answer or you
know could conceivably convince their
their TA that they're on the right track
but before we get to how do you turn off
an experiment which i think is an
interesting question in the context of
of pursuits where there may not be an
answer we may never detect gravitational
waves and the CMB for example may be its
will be impossible to detect dark matter
who knows but we'll talk about that in a
minute but before then I want to talk
about how do you decide to start an
experiment what gave you the hutzpah
as we say the gumption the gall if you
will to start this incredibly ambitious
many tens of millions of dollars
experiment that you've raised with your
collaborators and and what gives you the
notion that it's time to pursue
something and start off on something
that could be a 20 30 40 year quest well
that's easy to answer
is when I started which is more than 15
years ago the field was so way back
different than now the situation was
quite easy in a sense because we have
had we had had few detectives few
technologies very very powerful but
small scale detectors and they were
searching specifically for this
hypothetical candidate for that matter
which we call the weakly interacting
massive particle so designed
specifically for that to measure the
tiny energy that would be released in a
material if this hypothetical particle
would care to scatter of an atom of that
material and so we were talking about
these beautiful cryogenic kilometers at
that time in the head explore their
little region of this so-called
parameter space namely the interaction
strength of a wimp with a nucleon and at
that time these technologies the scaling
up of those technology was already clear
then that was very painful costly and
technically technologically very
challenging so I happened to attend a
meeting at the Snowmass meeting in
Colorado I think it was and I listened
to a lot of these Dark Matter talks and
so the picture of the status of the art
at that time and I connected quickly to
the developments that I was doing for
NASA for gamma-ray astrophysics I had
been developing this liquid xenon
detectors for detecting the radiation
the nucleosynthesis from supernovae from
Nova and so I decided I taught that it's
my my detector would be actually better
and more scalable than this technology
of the time and that's how I got the
idea of proposing the xenon experiment
mm-hmm so and if I'm not mistaking of a
patent related to that gamma-ray yeah
that was with one of my graduate
students mm-hmm was a light detecting
device we did a lot of work in the lab
with his Nobel liquefied gases and so
then I settled on to liquid Zener and a
lot of the work was done for as I said
as a Content Ellis
to use it in a Compton telescope for
imaging gamma rays mm-hmm from let's say
nucleosynthesis in stars
what is xenon how does it compare to say
helium which you can go down to the
supermarket and buy a balloon full but
we have had hard time to to detect
electrons in helium or to actually see
scintillation from it so the advantage
of xenon all these rare gases is that it
is the most amazing in terms of when you
cool it down when you liquefy it in
terms of ionizer and scintillator so it
gives you the highest yield the largest
number of photons per unit energy of
free electron per unit energy that gives
you signals that you want to have
available to detect some radiation so
it's a great radiation detection medium
mm-hmm
it is in addition very easy I mean with
time after 15 years now we learned out
to make it clean mm-hmm to remove
electronegative impurities stuff oxygen
like which eat easily electrons and if
you lose the signal
you know we're talking about a handful
of electron when we talk about detecting
the energy of a document the particle
interaction so even few electrons loss
is detrimental so we need to keep this
material clean we learned how to do it
the other advantage compared to let's
say argon or helium is that when you
liquefied the temperatures relatively
warm so as I say sometimes easy
cryogenics compare let's say to what
you're used to right so we have invented
cryocoolers pulse tube refrigerators
which can keep this xenon in my lab we
used to be in small detector size we
used to use nitrogen and I'll call and
make him alas I was here with so it's
hard to keep a detector for years and
years if you want
so mechanical coolers have come very
handy and we have made a lot of progress
on that for their specific liquid xenon
temperature mm-hmm let's say minus
hundred degree or so C mmm-hmm because
most of the cryocoolers you find on the
market
are optimized for liquid nitrogen mm-hmm
typically right so Foley cuisine and we
had to develop with the company in Japan
a specific rule about the refrigerator
so it's very good ionizer scintillator
you can keep it clean you and then for
dark matter or research is another great
advantage or requirement that you have
is that there are no intrinsic ready
activities because you're searching for
a very rare event if you have the
example is the argon liquid argon is
also a very good candidate for dark
matter miss targets and detector medium
mmm-hmm but you have the big problem of
the argon 39 intrinsic radioactivity
which gives you a background of rate and
so of course we have solved that as well
today because we are trying to extract
this argon from wells and remove this
intrinsic reactivity in then on you
don't have intrinsic radio activities
other than maybe the Krypton traces of
Krypton mmm-hmm and we have learned
again with time how to be still
we say this team yes cryogenic
distillation is being used a lot we have
huge distillation column on the Zenon
setup to remove the Krypton let's say no
because Krypton has this tiny amount of
Krypton 85 which is so all these things
make it and also I think coming back to
helium you have to see also where most
of the work went you know because still
today in my lab in many other labs we
are learning about the fundamental
physics the micro physics sometimes we
say oh this liquid we still have a lot
of things we don't understand the
recombination process because the
mechanisms through which these light and
charges are producing these materials
are quite complex
there are interplay between applying an
electric field to keep the free
electrons separate from the parent ion
stuff which eats the scintillation and
the excitement's which are forms and go
to ground state giving you light can be
formed also through the recombination
process so it's a very complicated
physics and also physics that we had to
learn to find out a very low energies
right because the work I did with not
within the NASA
frame
thing was many the energies the famous 5
11 kV line and now you're asking what is
the energy that a nuclear recalled from
a whimp interaction gives you and this
is few kV Johan and so the first
question I had when we started Zenon was
how many electrons do you expect from a
kv of a nuclear recall which I didn't
know because I was dealing with gamma
rays how about you know what is a
nuclear accord right so we started to
make experiments with neutrons in the
lab to produce neutral a nuclear recoil
from neutron scattering on Zener and
measuring the Heald how many charges how
many photons you find in these detectors
in order essential question to calibrate
yeah so and we still haven't finish this
quest because of course we want to go
lower and lower in energy right and so
on and so forth but it's an example I
bring always my proposal the Zen
proposal I the threshold
I don't remember 10 or 20 kV as an
energy threshold when we first did the
first prototype even xenon 10mm we could
show that the energy threat so much much
was much lower than that and the reason
is that we had no idea that we could go
so low I mean nobody knew really how low
in threshold but now you know these
detectors can be a single photon
sensitive single electron sensitivity so
that's something you learned with time
so the current limits that that you have
have achieved with xenon are really are
the most competitive in the world I
would say although we should say and
maybe I'm curious because I I can't
resist I have an expert and an Italian
expert no less what do you think about
this dama excess that's been going on
since I was a graduate student that
seems to say that suggests that there is
not only a dark matter
existing particle but it it behaves
exactly as you'd expect from the sort of
distribution of dark matter particles in
our galaxy and the relative increase or
decrease is sort of a wind and running
into the wind and out of the wind as the
earth our orbits around the Sun
each year and and and getting the
so-called annual modulations this is a
many many Sigma I forget how many it is
by now but they claim as last 12 or more
yeah a few weeks ago again at this
conference so yeah so tell me what do
you yeah when I was a grad student it
was five Sigma there have increased the
significance of this modulation they
clearly see a beautiful signal which
modulates with the right phase and it's
just it just remains as of today unclear
what the hell is doing that because if
that were coming from the venire wimp
hypothesis the same whims that we're
looking for in these detectors and many
others based on that rate on that
amplitude we would have to see a huge
signal which we haven't seen and so the
only way to answer that question
modulation is indeed the most direct and
beautiful way of discovering a win and
so for that we have actually made a
search with our own xenon data as you
know 100 data to search for any
modulation and test for lab to philic
models and whatever we still don't find
anything so the question is why is it so
special sodium iodide which is the
target that this experiment uses after
so many years since I started myself we
have finally come to the point where we
have other experiments using that same
technology testing the dama signal and
for Chinese experiments as of today they
haven't reached the sensitivity or the
statistics good enough to say yes or no
so they keep taking data and I'm waiting
we don't find the signals in then we
don't find it in other detectors so it
remains a mystery
and so we don't go there they insist but
if I were the Dhamma people I would have
taken my detector and moved it somewhere
else I'll give it to somebody else to
take some data and analyze the data my
understanding is there a little bit very
stubborn on keeping there yeah so is it
natural not to be stubborn and one of
the things that that that was so
resonant with me
in the film chasing Einstein which is
your one of your debut it's probably
your debut in the on the big screen and
a wonderful documentary which is
available for people to purchase online
iTunes YouTube etc and they cut to you
and they show you along with some I
guess you're listening to Shakira in the
background very elegant very and they
and they show you and then they show you
going into lab and you're in the lab
you're with your students you're clearly
at home
[Music]
morning the wiring was you I was
screaming at the other girl the other
student but you left it around and you
say a lovely thing that's you know again
resonated with me very strongly and you
say this is my baby this is my baby this
is my baby
and I love it every time I come in here
my students you know sometime I shout I
scream and shout really I hate to see
those cable ties left hanging and I'm
sure you find some if your cable tie is
hanging it means in your house you also
and we is going to want to have a guy
like you so I keep telling them you have
a better chance to find a woman you know
one tone has been operating for more
than one and a half year now so we're
very close to open the box and and see
what what nature is for us you want to
be confident and excited and hopeful
that maybe this time is the time and you
will see a sign of dark matter it's it
spoke to me in that this sort of
personification or anthropomorphizing
your experiment which is which is
something you know we all bleed cry and
sweat on our experiments and I don't
think the average you know layperson
appreciates just how hard it is to do
these results especially given the fact
that we seem to come up you know at
least from some perspectives of null
detections of no no positive results we
have not yet detected as I said
convincing evidence for you know
inflationary origin of the universe if
you will we may never and it may be may
be that inflation did take place but we
don't have the sensitivity and never
will or it could be that inflation
didn't take place and it might be some
other alternatives how do you continue
to persist in the face of this so the
Dhamma folks clearly feel they have
something to prove to the community and
that they are not being accepted at face
value I don't know of any other field
where such a large statistical
significance would be dismissed but
let's yeah
so we're where do where do you get your
yeah when do we get as experimentalist
when do we realize it's time to wrap up
when I started the field was a certain
stage and they made a lot of sense to
jump in and in fact the major
achievement that I feel I've made with
my collaboration and experiment is
really to explore not one or two
but four or five orders of magnitudes
from where we were then in terms of
testing the interaction strength or
whims with Matt you know excluding cross
sections which are lower lower lower for
5 volts magnitude in about 10 years 12
years is a major dealing in these than
any other fields huge swathes it and now
we're getting to the point where we're
making these detectors more and more
sensitive larger and larger mm-hmm there
were the scalability vision that one had
everybody knew but I mean you have this
noble liquid you can make them large
we're talking about not few hundred few
tenths of a kilogram we're talking now
about eight thousand kilograms ten
thousand kilogram of target we just
never been done and with that kind of
step now we want to seize the last
little bit of this so-called theoretical
prediction we are basing our detector
the detectors have been designed
specifically for a particle candidate
which is called a win so all these
detectives have been designed
specifically to search from mostly
massive wings and search has been done
mostly for tens of GeV hundreds of GV up
to the t v-- scale massive wings for
which this target specifically Zenon is
very very good because it has a lot of
nucleons the xenon atom is very large
and if a wimp scatters off a nucleus it
likes to scatter with all the nucleus
nucleons coherently so the larger the
the nucleus you have the better you are
off in the spin independent so-called
way so now we reach the point where we
are going to exclude maybe just one or
the remaining we we are separated from a
level of background that we can't avoid
despite all our smart which is the
neutrinos and so neutrinos from the Sun
from the atmospheric neutrino the
supernova neutrino going to give us a
signal soon but we have that last one
order magnitude maybe towards the many
two separating us from the signal of
neutrinos and so I think at that point
you have to stop in the sense that you
turn your detector into a beautiful
neutrino detector but there are many
others so the the natural stopping time
is
company to the to the time when the
neutrino signal is going really to make
it impossible for you to find a signal
from wimp if it is so at the level of
neutrino so but we still have a way to
go because with the current generation
of experiments about the star the xenon
and tone we're going to go still an
order of magnitude above the neutrino
floor almost and then if we're still
finding nothing there is a little bit
more and a lot of pain to get there
because it's amazing how you scale them
up but you gain very very little yeah
exponentially small and then a certain
point you have to stop because I mean
you can't even distinguish these
particles if they exist from the more no
unexpected particles such as neutrinos
so we do know when we will stop I will
stop then yeah maybe he baby I'm still
hopeful that in the next round which
still was going to last four or five
years from now
mmm of search searching for about
another four five years so this decade
for me is going to be critical because
we are going to start to search
competing after the experiment with the
same technology starting and we are
competing to start at the same time we
might have we will have a liquid organ
as well experiment starting this decade
the LHC is starting again after the
shuttle
we have indirect detection with this
beautiful telescopes from Ice Cube so
the Fermi still out there and we have
EMS out there so again we said that last
decade actually yeah exactly I know we
keep saying the same thing but but we
are going more and more down right so in
terms of theoretical framework I mean of
course our friends theorists are so
smart they'll keep coming up with
alternative and you know very well
already the absence of a signal in all
these channels from direct detection in
direct direct has prompted a wealth of
searches in other in neighboring energy
region so low mass win searches with
accelerator with beautiful
little technologies because the growth
sessions shoots up at low mass so you
don't need such large detectors and we
have a lot of effort going on a low mass
and so eventually this decade again at
least from the direct detection which is
the most in my opinion direct way of
finding this particle in the from the
Hale of this galaxy should be concluded
because if we still don't find it it's
decade there will be very little
separating us from the neutrino okay
well in March of 2030
you and I are gonna be back here so I
mentioned that I have a favorite quote
comes from Oscar Wilde a quotes in a
book or his writing Lady Windermere's
Fan he has a character Lord Darlington
quip the definition of a cynic is a man
who knows the price of everything but
the value of nothing and I think it's
sometimes hard to convince people you
know when they asked me what I'm looking
for and I say mostly nothing or static
or or whatever noise noise yeah we spent
all our days looking at noise and trying
to get understanding or trying to
understand it and model it etcetera
misconceptions of scientists first of
all they think we all have beards and we
can we are rubbing our beards and and
that's obviously not true and and either
one of our cases but I think there is
the sort of impression that you know
it's only science if you make a
discovery you know there's sort of
positivist you you have to actually have
something clearer rather than ruling
things out in the film there's a young
physicist postdoc who says you know
every paper should be celebrated like a
triumph like it was a great it was a
great quote yeah and I only think there
is some value in that I think there is
this tendency to look at people like
Einstein you know who's the film name
say character and chasing Einstein and
you know kind of hold him up this level
of authority and sort of almost like a
halo effect that no nothing that he did
could could possibly have failed and
been wrong
in fact as we know he made many many
blunders and some say he made more
blunders and not than the actual
successes I don't know if I agree with
that I think he would say he could have
had a good career if he didn't but but
you know a lot of what comes up in
physics is serendipitous and we don't
expect it the discovery of the Cosmic
Microwave Background the CMB that I
studied was completely serendipitous a
beautiful one that is clary of the of
the acceleration of the universe of dark
energy that was also serendipitous they
were looking for exactly the opposite
and I wonder you know if by focusing
maybe this is just too philosophical to
get into but discoveries of you know
your your countryman Galileo Galilei he
he discovered things completely by
accident and then applied scientific you
know principles and then the scientific
method towards sussing out all the
details of that new field that he and
basically single-handedly invented by
virtue of this exquisite technology that
he pioneered I see similarities with you
you you pioneer this tool you've
vacuumed up all of this parameter space
and that's sort of a natural thing to do
but I worry you know I wonder sometimes
if what's driving us Galileo never
really released the plans for his
telescope so that even his friend Kepler
could reproduce it because he wanted to
keep making these low hanging fruit
discoveries himself and I wonder you
know is that driven by this competition
as you know my my book I focus a lot on
competition and whether or not what role
the Nobel Prize plays in fact in the
film you open in your office I guess I
haven't been there yet I hope to someday
visit you in your office but but with a
poster of Marie Curie and you talk the
first thing that comes out is about the
Nobel Prize and how she want to and I
wonder is that a motivation for you I
know you're your advisor one and of all
prize and and obviously it's it's a it's
a it's a very dominant theme overarching
both of our fields does it play does it
play a role in you personally is it
something that influences you personally
I have to say no to be honest we are
embedded in this idea that of course
that's the highest home and you can get
and it would be absolutely great it's
true but he never played a role I have
to say because actually I see that when
people get the Nobel Prize directly I
had two good friends from Rubio to
George Harper I was very close to this
too
scientists but they changed completely
they get completely paranoid and crazy
yeah I don't like it Nobel Prizes a
ticket to your funeral because you never
do anything good after you win I know so
I I don't look forward to that and of
course the statement I made about Madame
Curie was very natural because well
she's no no she is the first woman and
the one who got it twice so it's such
different times and I wonder I don't
know how she behaves after probably she
was still normal
yeah I am more proud about seeing what
I'm curing
in reading some other biographies but
real woman yeah because we tend to
forget that the scientists like you and
me ever life yeah let's talk about that
I think you very you know both of us are
parents of daughters yeah and and and I
know that you know that in addition to
to Margaret Burbage and V Rubin spending
some time here
Maria Kephart mayor was here and when
she won the Nobel Prize her son told me
that the newspaper said La Jolla
housewife wins Nobel Prize and you see I
wonder you know what is your how do you
think of yourself are you a scientist
are you a mother how do you picture
yourself as a human being what what what
what defines you to you I am what I am I
am a woman and I happen to like to be in
the lab to build great technology
instruments and I am most proud of my
daughters because that's I used to say
and I wrote it down they are the best
experiments I made the most successful
experiment I ever made and I would never
do anything differently of course you
still feel guilty about the time you
took away from them because the lab
doesn't have time I mean the birthday
missing but they they knew when they
grew up stronger by knowing that his
mother as always something on her mind
she's thinking while she's cooking yeah
but to me that's and I want to instill
in every young woman and student today
approaching science that they can do the
science they have to do the science but
without forgetting that they're women
and caring to find a guy or whoever they
want and be happy
they're the rest of their persona make
babies because I mean I think that every
woman should have experience I mean and
I always felt that I actually wrote Ohio
I feel I always felt stronger than my
colleagues I was the first woman in the
physics department so a lot you can
imagine I've been always alone in these
meetings very very much alone
so I'm vaccinated I never cared though
right because when I then got pregnant
of Julia at Columbia I mean the people
with problems were more than my
colleagues than myself because they were
not used to see right and the bias is
large I mean what are you doing here you
should be home resting I say no idea but
you know you have to keep going and
these young women today have to know
mm-hmm the women like the Vera Rubin and
I'm sure Margaret I mean women can have
a life yeah and be a great scientist
that's enough to exclude one doesn't it
to screw the other yeah it will be a
pity in fact what I find most sometimes
said is to see colleagues smart women
who actually made the choice of MIT
renounces and didn't decide at the right
time to fulfill other dreams in their
life and then eventually they regret and
then it's too late
yellow I think we should encourage yeah
it's the hardest possible thing you
could do and I'm speaking as from male
perspective but I know it's a lot harder
but but being a parent is you know it is
an experiment and you hope that they do
they're not null experiments and then
they yield good results I have to say
that I am you know you would enjoy
coming over and helping with my twin
girls because they produce a lot of dark
matter in diapers so you have first-hand
experience direct experience so there
are a lot of ways we could we could go
with from here but I do want to just
maybe close out the discussion with one
of the ways that you inspire physicists
like me as as a leader and it's
something interesting that kind of
relates back to Einstein so you know
Einstein was asked to be the first
president of the new nation of Israel
and he was like why should I do that
because you're smart yeah but but really
there's a halo effect where people think
you know someone can do one thing that
it translates immediately over into some
other discipline which it doesn't but
you've managed to do two things that are
totally different right to excel in your
branch of physics and to also be a
scientific manager and a leader and
there's there's I think it's it's almost
harder to do that as I say you know as I
said earlier it's not like herding cats
at least cats basically stay on a planar
surface but you know butterflies are
hurting neutrinos or dark matter wimps
how do you how did you do that how do
you do that what I didn't learn any
management skill no we and I think some
people have it better than others I mean
I think my mother for that is that
intuition that we have in understanding
people I'm reading people right I don't
think very long to figure out when to
talk to you in certain ways mm-hmm and
so I managed to keep together this
collaboration which grew from 20 people
to almost wonder people and I'm still
managing that but the way I do it is
still my own way sometimes I go a bit
off the tangent but typically I use my
so called intuition is this connection
that I have with people I can't read
very easily and I know debating like I
definitely I motivate my students are my
babies I mean I care a lot about every
member of this collaboration yeah and
you see you see a lot of your colleagues
usually treating their students like
someone who can see you can see only
once a week maybe once even a month
mm-hmm for much just kidding my saying
and for me is everyday life I see and I
want to know everything what they do I
mean so and it's true I always am
curious but the reason why I'm curious
how are you doing how is it going with
your wife how is your kid my person it's
because I know first of all this is
probably selfish
yeah because somebody happy mmm-hmm
what's better yeah so when I when I
sense that something is wrong
which is a personal matter I tried to
help them solve it because I know that
they otherwise there's an impostor hmm
he's also bit selfish but I do care
about what they're doing with their life
as well and try to help them you know
and try to help them also become not
just great scientists but also great
human beings mm-hmm and if that means
also learning how to make a good
espresso yeah
and now to cut cable ties well not think
of them as sloppy we will have workshop
or not to make the best lasagna hope to
get a great woman if you don't do
nothing good very true so my final
question this question I asked everyone
from Nobel laureates Pulitzer Prize
winners entrepreneurs etc I've been so
gracious with their time as you have
with yours to come on this podcast and
that is we focus here at the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination on
this question of imagination which is
naturally connected to creativity the
unique human capacity for reason i think
is is what sets us apart what
distinguishes us but the question of you
know Kant pedagogically can you can you
teach someone to be the next Illinois
prio I mean can you teach somebody to do
the kinds of things the skill set the
meta skills that we need to be the
successes in our field is that a
teachable skill or is it you have to be
born with it obviously lasagne you can
teach but you know something like you
know cuisine I wouldn't recommend on
anybody even if you were my teacher so
is it something in as a physicist can
you teach someone to be a physicist a
lot of theoretical physicists say you
know I've interviewed have said well we
tend to think of everyone in theoretical
physics tyne and so I can't be like
Einstein so I won't even try but but
we're experimentalist we're dealing with
the real hard core substantive life and
and actually contact with nature not
only and I'm not disparaging theorists
there might some of them are my best
friends
but but can you teach creativity can you
teach imagination that allows you to be
successful in our field of experimental
astrophysics no Brian you cannot teach
someone to be creative to be imaginative
that's really something that you have
but you can help a lot whatever is the
little bit that you have in someone
channel it in the right direction but I
have seen over and over with my student
my postdoc you can make them better but
if they didn't have to begin with the
curiosity the creativity they're never
going to invent something in the lab
they're going to be more follower than
leader in that sense but no leader in
terms of taking initiative and making
something new not of nothing I at least
my experience been so far that is hard
to teach that's not a skill mm-hmm yeah
so you can teach them to be great
experimentalist I have turned the best
theoretical mm-hm
physics student into a good experimental
Easter's that usually I don't get from
them that innovative thing that you get
from someone who is really as I say any
more I want and I'm not as good as some
of them but you really see that that is
something that these people just have it
yeah they just get better and better at
it but you can beat that you can't even
ask me something your name but maybe I'm
wrong no that's funny well such a
pleasure having you on the arthur c
clarke center for human imaginations
into the impossible podcast i want to
encourage folks to subscribe and like
and review and rate on itunes and
elsewhere wherever you get your podcasts
wherever you watch online on YouTube and
elsewhere I don't know anything you want
to promote you're going to be giving a
colloquium here and at UC San Diego in
April I believe and we can't wait to see
that we just had our public event you're
around is the rest of this quarter is
the visiting Margaret burbage professor
anything you want to talk about that we
didn't get a chance to cover on today's
podcast
I just wish here like I do Bitto
Colombia but certainly sounds like
to encourage every student I've been
meeting with the undergraduate of women
in physics I will meet with the graduate
students in physics women in physics but
every young man and woman was in love
with physics to come and see me on
campus while I'm here I'll talk to me
because I think the future of course in
like in everything else is in these
young minds and we ought to give them
whatever we have learned because as I
grow older you realize you have a lot to
tell to share with the younger people of
course but if you don't have a chance to
talk you will never be able to pass the
message so I'm here so they should come
I'm very honored and grateful for you
spending your time here but thank you
find more discoveries together thank you
thank you
right the only thing we can be sure of
about the future is it it'll be
absolutely fantastic
[Music]
[Music]